how much is the us-china relationship
one today China stands as the greatest
global rival to the United States but
the world's two largest economies are
also inextricably linked America's
government has accused Chinese military
personnel of corporate espionage the
latest escalation in the growing rivalry
between the world's two largest
economies but extensive and growing
trade links will make it difficult for
either nation to sever ties with their
financial frenemy US exports to China
exceeded 31 billion dollars the first
quarter this year while China sold more
than a hundred billion dollars worth of
goods to America during the same period
Apple America's largest company by
market value not only has 62 suppliers
in china but it also has earned 9.3
billion dollars there in the first
quarter this year that was a fifth of
its total revenues and there are other
US tech giants that stand to suffer from
any trade breakdown IBM Oracle Amazon
other big losers could be in the
aerospace aviation and auto industries
according to the international trade
administration American tech
corporations may worry that exports and
earnings will take a hit if the
relationship between these two nations
breaks down but according to the US
government it's undeniably chinese tech
expertise that's made these recent hits
on corporate america